[Music]
everyone snoop entre with Collider and I
am here with the group behind mope
congratulations on getting into Sundance
let me start with that thank you I'm
sure when you were making it you're like
we're going to Sunday it's for sure
absolutely absolutely
we were I was obviously our call but we
were we're so happy I mean it's uh we
tried to make the best way possible and
we hope we got in I listened the fact is
almost everyone watching this thing will
not seen the film yet so talk a little
bit about what the film is about and
especially what does the term mean okay
somos a mope is a low-level porn
performer someone who does the dirtiest
nastiest work and porn like macaques
gangbangs really unusual stop smelling
feet unusual stuff that's you know it's
not that it's tough to get performance
to do so basically mopes are these guys
that dream of being big stars so the
movies set in it's a true story set in
2010 about to low-level mopes Steve
driver as they're struggling to make it
in the porn industry and they kind of
spiral spiral down a path of destruction
so it's funny it's sad but it's it's a
crazy true story I definitely have to
ask you what was it when did you feat
when we first heard the story were you
like this is a movie no I was vaguely
familiar of it when it happened in 2010
and then years later I came across a
couple articles about it and then
immediately I knew because I was looking
for our first project to do for a first
film and I just responded to the story
it has everything I'm looking for in a
project violence comedy violence but
it's up but it's like it's a it's kind
of a tonal shift between humor and drama
and ultimates a tragedy but I just I
found it captivating well when you're
dealing with something this subject
matter yeah obviously you can't go like
nc-17 or maybe you can but talk a little
bit about the the line in terms of what
you wanted to show and how important is
showing that stuff versus just sort of
talking about it well you know nothing
like nude there's a plenty of nudity in
the phone but it's always to create a
sense of realism if you actually go on a
porn set which I
I have in me the actors here have people
walking around naked there's all the
guys regardless if they're talking about
sports or the weather they're kind of
fondling themselves preparing themselves
for the scene so once you absorb all
these details you realize you're gonna
have to get a little graphic to
accurately depicted and our big thing
was making sure that people in the porn
industry would watch this film and be
like oh that's spot-on that's what I'm
I'm you know I want it to be feel very
real one of the things that you had said
that we talked about was like what would
like when the nudity came up it wasn't
intended to be titillating or sexy I was
very vulnerable you know yeah kind of
raw it was that it was getting across
the risk and the vulnerability people
were putting out there
I just Here I am sure I'm curious for
all the actors actually you talked a
little bit about when you get the script
for something like this
is it something are you a little bit
nervous about you know if you don't I
mean and talk a little bit about what it
was like on set because again I haven't
seen it yet so I don't know how much you
have to show and you know what I mean
you had a lot of reputation when I first
read the script as whether I wanted to
do it because of the world that it
depicts and whether I was able to do it
because of the journey they and that
Steve Antin go on it it's a hugely
emotional roller coaster and I think on
set I mean you were really good about
not doing things that we weren't
comfortable with and so apparently
uncomfortable with everything but yeah I
think there was for me that and going
what's the news see for me it really
couldn't be about that it really has to
be about the story we'd have to be about
the relationship and there are moments
of bay thoughts and that's great but it
really kind of cuts through in an
emotional sense and I really was
considering on next you're in this world
that is to me who's not in the porn
world quite absurd at times and you have
to kind of ground that and I think from
script level and to actually shooting it
I think you know everyone actually was
really involved doing that yeah yeah
when I first ready I was I knew it was a
script I wanted to do like I definitely
had to do this but it was definitely
some hesitation
I was very nervous about some scenes and
even though the script was great there's
talking Lucas is on a different level
because he makes you feel so safe
whether on set or before we start
shooting he's a master manipulator
honestly that might be because before we
start shooting I pretty much gave my
life to Lucas I'm like I trust you 100%
completely whatever it is obviously I
was like and I just thought the sound I
just can imagine me just yeah yeah he
was like um like check on everyone in
between takes everybody okay everyone
cool like you know if people had to
leave the room collect themselves it was
a very trusting set a lot of respect
which let us really go there when the
cameras were rolling in a confident way
he you knew the story wanted to tell
that's why I when I read it as as as an
actor oh my gosh I read so when I read a
script it the empathy and the human
story of these of everyone in it um it
it was it was there it didn't I
it didn't matter that it was the porn
industry because he wrote he didn't
write the script about the porn industry
he wrote it about the the human side of
these two guys following their dream and
what went down around them and it was um
it got me really excited and then of
course you know after talking to this
guy um it I was pretty I was sold they
never told me it was set in the porn
world we're not shooting a porn okay I
misinterpreted sorry no I honestly like
I remember saying my agents like I
really like this and I like I like dark
stuff I like like I like you know
troubling stories because you know it's
everyone has troubling experience and
stuff but I was nervous about doing
something that I might have to sort of
explain to my daughter what
it's working on or you know whatever so
I talked to her mother about it just
like I think it's it's okay you know you
don't have to sort of give her all the
details but if you want to tell her it's
about you know someone who has troubles
and you it's a dark story that's okay
but it's interesting just even as us
actors been like uh I'm I'm interested
in this world but I'm also well as the
audience will be like I don't know this
world this is a weird world they were
kind of going into yeah
it's sort of that experiences I think we
all had it and then when to get into
it's like oh we're just dealing with
people you know yeah any apprehension
yeah when I read my my part I was like
oh like my characters had some really
horrible things so that was a little
like you know took a lot of
decision-making to like do I want to do
that but but it serves a purpose and and
and it you know help the story along I
mean it was really the script is a
beautiful story about this friendship
and this need for love you know even if
it's mistaken and convoluted I'm always
curious about the editing process talk a
little bit about what you learned in the
Edit and maybe any changes that were
made as a result of any early screenings
yeah I had a great editor Kern Saxton
who you know was amazing and I I let you
know I gave him a lot of free rein I
would shoot where is he where is he he's
way to Mara now now he was great you
know most of the editing was cutting
like the script was a hundred pages long
but for some reason the first cut was
two hours and 45 minutes and so we had
to you know I kind of learned about like
what you don't need like I think and you
know moving forward in projects I'd
probably shoot shorter scripts and it's
interesting what you can convey in just
a look instead of like a next scene with
a bunch of exposition you know it's it's
just about I think getting to the core
of what you're trying to say in the film
and any scene that isn't about that it's
just he's gonna go in the edit sure yeah
for each of you and this is a delicate
one because I don't want to spoil
anything in the move
but I also want to talk about this so
you read the script you know that
there's some interesting material and
this thing is was there a day or when
you're reading the script
can you talk about a scene that maybe
you were really nervous before shooting
began you're like oh this is gonna be a
really hard day on set it might be Tonya
won't see me it's like the scene with
Tampa where it's like a group it's a
gangbang and it's it gets very intense
and it gets very it just is it is a
scene about the sort of dark darker side
of this world and and and the darker
side of just investigating that that
part of you know sexuality or you know
any of that stuff and yeah it was it was
nerve-wracking but at the same time
Lucas made us all feel very safe it was
paced well we you know we we would do it
and sort of check in with each other and
and I mean it was when I read the script
I knew that that would probably won and
I'll never do a scene like that again
it's not written and I've never read a
scene like that but um
Tammis story is real and true she didn't
she wasn't part of the porn world she
got kind of swept into it
and didn't even know she was there until
it was too late and it's it's pretty
pretty heartbreaking I think I think
there is that side of the porn world
where people that are on the street and
do in our doing drugs and our desperate
and they they get into it that way and
not because they're dreaming to be porn
stars and she I mean in my character
never got into it but that day on set
was I knew it was obviously gonna be
that way when I first talked to Lucas
and I don't think any of us could have
done that scene without the way it was
shot in the way he set it up and almost
in a quarry choreographed way it allowed
us to when you're put in a box kind of
it allowed us to feel it's safe and go
there and be like we we know we know
what's not going to get crossed what
lines aren't going to get crossed and
then it allowed us to be creative within
it so use it
him yeah that was that was a hard she in
there I'm obviously Steven Tom you know
they lived and there there was a scene
with Steve's dad and I think I was
really nervous about that because
Steve's dad is still alive and so it was
about depicting his son on on screen and
now that was a very nerve wracking of
that relationship and Lucas introduced
me to his father in it that was there I
really felt such a level of
responsibility at that point I think
there were several holidays including
that day but there was such a level of
responsibility to this man who I knew
would be watching this movie and
thinking of his son and me not being his
son but really trying to kind of embody
that relationship I had a scene with
Brian that I thought was probably one of
the hardest scenes for me um it was very
emotional scene and I before we even
started shooting I told Lucas I don't
know I can do his scene but he didn't
have any worries and and on the day he
gave me Liberty to do whatever it is I
needed to do to get into that space and
he made it very safe and hopefully it
turned out alright yeah but that was
very very grueling day in addition to
all the other scenes that you guys have
spoken about because it's they're very
humorous moments in this movie but it
gets pretty dark as well so there are
plenty of days that a lot of us were
yeah it was it was very hard with that
darkness though like with my character
who is a very real guy who I still talk
to and Lucas introduced me to him on a
porn set but we still talked up to you
know last week I didn't have a lot of
sexual stuff to do but there's a very
dark violent thing that happens you know
at the end and actually that was like I
felt a big responsibility to get it
right and not not be melodramatic not
back off from it cuz he's still dealing
with these very real effects of what
happened that day
and he's gonna be watching and so I
think that was the thing was a
responsibility to all these real people
that existed and do exist in this world
but that again was a credit to Lucas's
directing in the script was that this is
all real and so if we don't do it the
way it happened and we don't depict them
with the respect of what actually
happened you're actually not respecting
the incidents the traumatic things that
went down and so again that gave us the
permission and the safety to really just
dive into it I didn't share anything you
were really nervous about before filming
not rude not really I mean I sort of
talked about it earlier like my
character is sort of an oblivious racist
like he just doesn't get like he's not
aware of himself and so but I wasn't
really scared of when I saw it that
scene with tamp it's just so hard
crushing that's really difficult to
watch I'm basically out of time but I
did want to ask you real fast yeah and
if you don't mind a quick answer of
course the thing about this is that when
this is based on a true story real
people but you're also making a movie so
you have to tow that line of balancing
fact and fiction can you sort of talk
about towing that line and what you felt
you could take liberties with if
anything I've you could take liberties
with a lot of stuff I think I think as
long as the the film is true to the
essence of what the characters are to
the essence of what they are you're
gonna have to collapse stuff you're
gonna have to compress time and change
things but as long as you get the like
the essence of what the story's about
it's I think it's good I wouldn't change
anything drastic that altered the
dynamic of the entire story but of
course you know I never you know I never
met these guys so a certain ailment is
gonna be you know Zack knew Kirk and I
who wrote the script
we had to make up a lot of stuff but
because I met everybody like I knew how
these people talked and so I could I
could basically fill in the blank as
much as possible we haven't addressed is
that I think you took a risk with me
because Steve is actually biracial and
I'm not so I think that was
Keifer costing me bet like a thing we're
also all brainwashed you go with the
best actors you go with you have to make
choices like that you my answers always
go with the best actor who's gonna be
able to create this character in the
best way and it may be a slight
different thing but if it's the they're
the best then go with them totally um I
got to stop there and just say thank you
so much for coming in the studio I
cannot wait to see the film here at
Sundance and thank you and I hope it's a
huge it for you guys thank you very much
you